tristan thompson is allegedly expecting
his third child according to court
documents obtained by daily mail the 30
year old nba star is being sued for
child support by mara lee nichols a 31
year old personal trainer who says she
is pregnant with his baby and due to
give birth in december e.t has reached
out to tristan's lawyer for comment
of course the sacramento king star is
already dad to three-year-old daughter
true whom he shares with his ex khloe
kardashian 2-2 okay good one two three
he also has a four-year-old son prince
whom he shares with another ex jordan
craig according to the court docs
tristan's alleged third child was
conceived in houston during his 30th
birthday celebration in march at the
time of his birthday chloe shared these
family pics of tristan and true at his
party calling him her quote best friend
in the caption quote the ones that are
meant to be are the ones who go through
everything that is designed to tear them
apart and they came out even stronger
than they were before the good american
founder added quote thank you for
showing me everything you said you would
for the father you are for the best
friend i have in you i'm thankful that i
can do absolutely nothing with you and
it feels like everything i hope you know
today and every day how loved you are by
me and so many
and on thursday the 37 year old keeping
up with the kardashians star may have
hinted at the drama posting this cryptic
quote to her insta story i just don't
have time for negative energy and even
when i do i still don't i always want to
evolve and grow and mature emotionally
and according to daily mail in a
deposition from august 5th tristan
mentions chloe who he referred to as his
ex-girlfriend and the mother of his
child he also acknowledges having sex
with marley at a hotel after they
attended a party together
and while he claims they were only
together one night her lawyers are
saying the affair began at least five
months before his birthday and continued
after she got pregnant as for chloe and
tristan they split in june 2021 amid
continued allegations that the athlete
had once again been unfaithful of course
fans of keeping up with the kardashians
will recall the former couple first
split in february 2019 amid his cheating
scandal with kylie jenner's former
bestie jordan woods you know things
happen and of course i'm sorry and
apologetic as much as i can be the
makeout sesh marked the second time he
had publicly cheated on coco back in
2018 reports first surfaced that tristan
allegedly cheated on her with multiple
women while she was pregnant with true
and when eti caught up with the reality
star later that year she said she wasn't
focused on dating
you guys have been through so much in
your life but what are you what are you
looking for now you're not looking
i'm not but i'm not like inten i'm just
super happy and content and i'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true and i just i'm
having so much fun with her and when i
want to i will it's not some deliberate
thing that i think that hard about and
despite it all the two managed to
co-parent their little girl through the
ups and downs i think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style it's a beautiful thing
to get along with each other and for
your kids to see that in fact the two
rekindled their romance while
quarantining together amid the pandemic
and following their split a source told
et in september that tristan still quote
tries to get chloe back adding quote
chloe gave tristan several chances and
after new allegations decided it was
time to break things off the two are on
good terms and at the end of the day
chloe just wants true to have a good
relationship with her father
[Music]
you